Nautica of all time woody rotate no one
can tell around what to do or what not
to do the determination and the
intention of any kind of retaliation
remains with the government of the
Islamic Republic of Iran foreign
delegations have been in constant
contact with mr. Zarif the nature of the
situation is that we want to bring to
their attention how important the issue
is for us as a nation
acerbo joins us now live from Tehran and
I so just take us through what else said
abbas Mousavi had to say well he said
that Iran has written to the United
Nations Security Council and the
secretary-general of voicing their
condemnation that's what has happened
the assassination of general customs so
the money they've also summoned the
Swiss Charles D affaires now the United
States doesn't have a presence here so
the Swiss act as a go-between now
they've been summoned three times in
three days first over the assassination
second over the response to Iran's
response to Donald Trump and now again
responding to Donald Trump's tweet
saying that fifty two locations in Iran
had been highlighted including cultural
sites now he said that no one can tell
Iran how to act or what not to do but
Iran does not want war but are prepared
for any anything that the United States
may put towards a target Iran right now
emotions here are still very very high
there's imagery of dozens of the money
across Tehran in fact across the country
and we haven't seen crowds like this the
millions act on the streets since the
funeral of the founder of Iran Iran
Ayatollah Khomeini I said thank you I
said back there from Tehran what
mourners have gathered in their tens of
thousands to welcome home the body of
Qasem Soleimani the Iranian military
commander was assassinated by a u.s.
airstrike in Iraq on Friday so the man
whose body has now arrived in the holy
city of Mossad his body has brought back
to Iran early on Sunday earlier he was
carried in a procession through I was
and will later be flown to Tehran
president Donald Trump has sent a series
of tweets warning the US will hit Iran
harder than ever before if it takes
retaliatory action for Salam on is
killing Trump says his country will hit
52 Iranian sites if Iran targets
Americans